le préserver les emplois alain moyne
bressand monsieur monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
nos agriculteurs sont inquiets je
souhaite ici relayer leurs
préoccupations dans le contexte des
négociations sur le partenariat
transatlantique de commerce et
d'investissement entre la commission
européenne et les états unis
si négociations sont aujourd'hui menée
dans le plus grand secret elles font
l'objet de spéculations diverses
le report du vote qui devait avoir lieu
le 10 juin dernier au parlement européen
a renforcé les inquiétudes
le secrétaire d'état au commerce
extérieur déclarait le 8 mai 2015 que
les négociations n'avancent pas pourquoi
quels sont les points de blocage ces
questions sont importantes pour nos
agriculteurs
avec ce traité c'est l'avenir et la
qualité de notre modèle agricole qui
sont en jeu la loi d'avenir pour
l'agriculture d'octobre dernier a
surtout apporté des contraintes pour le
présent les exploitants sont noyés sous
les déclarations et les obligations
administratives nouvelle on comprend
leur inquiétude
aucun signal positif n'est à entrevoir
il suffit de voir par exemple le prix du
lait qui ne cesse de chuter en janvier
2014 la tonne de lait se vendait 392
euros
aujourd'hui on est aux alentours de 300
et ne dites pas comme d'habitude que
c'est la faute de l'arrêt des quotas il
suffit d'être un peu sur le terrain pour
comprendre qu'il n'en est rien
les agriculteurs en particulier les
jeunes sont catastrophés par le manque
de perspective d'avenir
on voit malheureusement de plus en plus
d'exploitations à l'abandon ne trouvant
pas de repreneur aussi monsieur le
premier ministre il est important que la
représentation nationale soit tenu
informé des négociations très
symptomatique de leur calendrier est de
leur contenu des agriculteurs attendent
des réponses
quelles actions concrètes le
gouvernement merci monsieur harlem désir
secrétaires d'état chargés d
affaires européennes merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député alain moyne
bressand je veux d'abord excusé matthias
fekl qui vient de partir avec le premier
ministre en déplacement en colombie et
en équateur et qui m'a demandé de
répondre à votre question
le tt ip le traité transatlantique tout
d'abord et vous l'avez rappelé est
aujourd'hui en cours de négociation
entre l'union européenne et les etats
unis le dixième cycle de négociation
s'ouvrira début juillet donc pour
l'instant il n'y a aucun accord pour
négocier il faut d'ailleurs être deux et
je veux souligner qu' à ce stade vous le
savez l'administration américaine
demande au congrès des états unis de
disposer de la trade promotion authority
c'est à dire du mandat qui lui permettra
réellement de conduire cette négociation
et pour l'instant cela est repoussé et
cela va de nouveau être examiné par le
sénat
tout au long de ces négociations la
france a mis en avant des exigences
précises et fixer des lignes rouges
ligne rouge notamment concernant
l'agriculture
d'abord nous l'avons dit nous ne
mettrons pas en négociation les règles
qui concernent la sécurité sanitaire des
aliments
nous refusons les ogm le boeuf aux
hormones le poulet chloré tout cela nous
ne l'accepterons pas dans le cadre de
ces négociations de même que nous avons
exclu des secteurs très sensibles
l'audiovisuel la protection des données
personnelles deuxièmement sur le plan de
la méthode et de la transparence à
laquelle vous avez appelé c'est pour
nous une exigence absolue
le mandat de négociation donné à la
commission européenne est désormais
public c'était une demande forte de la
france mais il faut aller plus loin en
permettant l'accès aux documents de
négociation dans les capitales des états
membres les états unis le refuse
il nous propose d'y avoir accès dans
leur ambassade c'est absolument
inacceptable parce que ce sont les états
membres des 28 qui devront donner leur
accord
et ensuite ce sont les parlements le
parlement de chacun des 28 états
manquent donc l'assemblée nationale et
parlement européen qui devront ratifier
un éventuel accord donc sur la
transparence comme sur les lignes rouges
nous partageons vos préoccupations et
nous les défendons je vous remercie
merci